sounds like it actually the exhibit
sounds very much like the experience I
had with the Rolling Stones I went on
the road with them when I was in my 20s
and sort of was in those places
backstage watching them from behind you
know from sitting on the stage and you
feel like they are the band that they're
the ones who lasted you know the beatles
broke up so long ago it's before I was
even aware of it so the rolling stones
are rock and roll at this point yes but
rich smooth your book is a pretty Frank
description of your relationship with
them and their relationship with each
other and you you suggest that perhaps
they're a bit like a married couple here
only in it for the money is that how you
describe the motive behind this
exhibition as well no I don't think I
mean what I would I what I'm saying is
there that's a friendship what's amazing
about the rolling stones is there Mick
Jagger and Keith Richards are
songwriters and what I was attracted to
buy them is if they are that they're me
their songs sort of an expression of
their friendship and at a certain point
those songs changed and became less
urgent and what happened is their
friendship sort of dissolved in the late
1970s I think in the rolling stones
actually broke up and they came back
together and you sort of wonder why
people are back together and I was sort
of questioning you know why are they
still doing what they're doing it's one
of the great mysteries there what's its
60 years and they're out there still
doing it so you have to you know
question its I always said it's like you
know you stay together for the kids
where the kids were grown up what what
do you think that the point of the
writing sentences is today as they head
through their seventies towards their
80s you know I it's interesting if you
The Rolling Stones heroes were guys like
Muddy Waters I'm from Chicago Muddy
Waters played until they had a carry him
out and the idea about Muddy Waters is
he could sit in a chair with the guitar
and make this incredible music and
that's sort of that's Keith Richards in
way but Mick Jagger's so about being
physical about moving about his body
about sex and as they get you know Mick
Jagger i think is a great grandfather
and when a great grandfather is kind of
about sex it brings up a whole new
question that's kind of about the baby
boomers and the way they sort of live
their lives and it's fascinating to
watch the game is Jimmy did make that
joke when he's talking to our reports
are saying it's now a question of lock
up your grandmother's I mean I mean it's
true it's true it's interesting it's
fattening when I suppose long time ago
they were these are the same questions
when I was touring with them in the 90s
the cuete were calling it the geritol
tour and calling into strolling bones
they were fifth 49 50 years old my age
now you know so and at the time Keith
Richards said no one's ever taken it
this far why not see how far can
actually be taken you know and it's sort
of like this and what amazes me is
whenever they're criticized that's when
they do their best work when they have
to sort of I think of him as like a guy
in a gunslinger in a western who pushed
the guns back on and one more time goes
back you know down in the street and
fights again sort of their last great
album with some girls I think and they
made it in the 70s right when the punk
rockers when Johnny Rotten was saying
the rolling stones are old get off the
stage that was in 1977 just finally what
about their style because this is going
to be a visual exhibition of a
significant contribution contributors to
style the way I always heard it is that
one morning Keith Richards couldn't find
his shirt and he put on Anita Pallenberg
shirt by accident and that changed the
way everybody dressed for the rest of
the world so basically when I was a kid
and I wanted to dress up like the
Rolling Stones I would get one of my
sister's shirts and that would make me
all the style in the world so I think
they've completely we're living sort of
in the world they created their so
everywhere you don't even take notice of
it